Recall from an earlier lesson that one
of the internet's fundamental design tenants is packet
switching. In a packet switch network, resources are
not reserved and packets are self containment. Every
packet has a destination IP address, and each
packet travels independently to the destination host. In
a packet switch network, a link may be
shared by multiple senders at any given time,
using statistical multiplexing as we learned in previous
lessons. Well packet switch networks have their advantages, in
particular it makes it easy to achieve high utilization
on a shared link, packet switch networks also have
the drawback that A large number of senders can
overload a network resource, such as a node or
a link. Note that circuit switch networks like the
phone network do not have this problem because every
connection effectively has allocated, dedicated resources.
For that particular connection until it
is terminated. So this problem that an attacker who sends allot of traffic
might exhaust resources is unique to
a packet switched network environment. So packet
switched networks are extremely vulnerable to
resource exhaustion attacks. Resource exhaustion Attacks a
basic component of security known as availability.
Let's take a look at other component of
security as well. In addition to Availability, we
would like the network to provide Confidentiality. For
example, if you're performing a sensitive banking transaction
or having a private conversation. With a friend.
You'd like the Internet to provide some level
of confidentiality. Another component of security is Authenticity.
Authenticity ensures the identity of the origin of
a piece of information. So, for example, if you're
reading a particular news article, you really may want
to know that the article came From the New
York Times website. As oppose to, from some other
place on the internet. Similarly, you might want to
know that, that information wasn't modified in flight. That
property is called Integrity. Which prevents unauthorized changes to
information as it traverses the network Now a security threat is
anything that might potentially cause a violation of one of these
properties. An attack, on the other hand, is an action that results
in the violation of one of these security
properties. So the difference between a threat and an
attack, is simply the difference between a violation
that could potentially occur. Versus an action that actually
results in a violation. let's look at a couple example attacks on
different components of security. let's start
by looking at an attack on Confidentiality.